now the latest from a Mississippi Town
hammered by a monster tornado last week
now that killed 22 people in all the
death toll was revived downward
yesterday the Twister flattened entire
neighborhoods and you can follow the
path of Destruction all the way into
Alabama most of the people who were
killed lived in a place called Roland
Fork Mississippi Omar villafranca has
been there talking with survivors Omar
good morning to you
good morning cleanup continues here in
Rolling Fork on that side of the street
homes will be demolished on this side
businesses are trying to clean up like
these 18 wheelers that are stacked on
top of me residents that we talk to here
saying that they were having problems
making ends meet even before this
disaster struck
the devastation goes on for miles
as the memories are piled up into heaps
days after the powerful tornado touched
down residents are still looking for
anything worth saving in the debris okay
put it to words
this is unbelievable Jeremy Grayson was
out getting food when the Twister tore
through his block I ran back here what
did you expect to see I was expecting to
see a house but uh I couldn't see none
would you hear it cries out for help you
can hear it echoing
all the way through all the way through
Grayson has lived here for his entire
life it was forgotten about before this
is basically the most intention that we
didn't had in our lives are you worried
that the state and other people are
going to forget about you here and
you're not going to be able to rebuild
that's a feeling shared by others in
Rolling Fork how can we we
and we don't have nothing
to build our foundation with
we need help Rolling Fork is located in
Sharkey County Mississippi where 35
percent of the population lives below
the poverty line it's among the poorest
counties in the state which itself has
almost 20 percent of its population
below the poverty line there's a real
lack of jobs around in the area but
Grayson says the community will still
rebuild the life is still here
communities still here it's just the
material things that are gone
Grayson said he got an alert on his
phone but he did not hear sirens well
emergency officials told us that the
tornado formed so fast they didn't have
time to activate the sirens Nate
Omar thank you